[Music]
spirit thus comes before us as absolute
freedom it is self-consciousness which
grasps the fact that it's certainty of
itself is the essence of all the
spiritual masses or spheres of the real
as well as of the supersensible world or
conversely that essence in actuality our
consciousness is knowledge of itself it
is conscious of its pure personality and
there and of all spiritual reality and
all reality is solely spiritual the
world is for it simply its own will and
this is a general will and what is more
this will is not the empty thought of
will which consists in silent descent or
ascent by a representative but a real
general will the will of all individuals
as such for will is in itself the
consciousness of personality or of each
and it is as this genuine actual will
that it ought to be as the self
conscious essence of each and every
personality so that each undivided from
the whole always does everything and
what appears is done by the whole is the
direct and conscious deed of each
there is a Claire
taury question that we should be asking
at this point in this section absolute
freedom and terror and paragraph 584 is
helping us to begin formulating it and
to begin answering that question there's
a bit of contemporary or just rather
closely connected earlier thought
presupposed in this that we'll have to
lay out but Hegel is really helping us
to ask this question well what is
absolute freedom and freedom itself is a
rather ambiguous term some people
conceive of freedom as simply being able
to do whatever it is that you want to do
or always having choices and that is not
what Hegel has in mind here although he
does have to take into account the
tendency of many people to try to push
freedom in that direction he would
actually look at that as a deformation
of freedom and and here we might think
of a distinction that gets made a little
bit later on but which is quite active
in modern thought that between positive
and negative freedom negative freedom is
what many people have in mind when they
can see if freedom as nobody interfering
with them getting to do what it is that
they they want to do in a sort of
superficial way positive freedom is
something a bit more robust and this is
distrusted by many of the advocates of
negative freedom Hegel is a big
proponent of positive freedom the
freedom to actually develop in the way
that you ought to incorporate within
your own life within your own so bring
up a word he's going to use your
personality what it is that is going to
bring you to your fulfillment which
might include connections with other
people and might include actually will
include giving up some freedoms that
that negative freedom would would really
stress and then we also have this term
absolute mixed in there as well right
absolute many people think of simply is
like you know whatever is at the very
end
you know the highest amount so absolute
freedom I'm getting to do anything that
you want you're like the god of your own
little universe again hey I would say
not what I have in mind at all absolute
would be freedom that could actually so
to speak make sense of itself and not be
binding itself by its own misuses of
freedom and this is not actually going
to be realized in this section this is
the ideal that is motivating the people
being discussed in this section so let's
turn to the text Hegel says spirit Geist
mind comes before us as the absolute
freedom what is it it is self
consciousness which not just any old
self consciousness which grasps the fact
that its certainty of itself is the
essence the vases the being the
importance of what is at the core of all
the spiritual masses or spheres of the
real as well as of the supersensible
world so what is he saying here let's
pause for a moment on this we have spent
a lot of time in the phenomenology
articulating out essentially following
what happened in the history of
development of consciousness according
to Hegel all of these spiritual domains
or if he likes the word masses you know
seers whatever you want to call them
these can be estates
you know like the first estate and the
nobility or the second estate the clergy
third estate everybody else pretty much
for the state the newspapers you know
this can be understood in terms of state
power and wealth this can be understood
in terms of you know the household and
what goes beyond the household this can
be understood in all sorts of ways
Hegel's point here is that every single
one of these at this point in
development has in essence has a core
because it's an organization of human
beings within society
so whether it's a candle makers guild or
a bunch of you know monks that it was
drawn into a monastery but are still
connected with the world in some respect
or the you know halls of government
there's essences he's not saying it's
the same single essence in every one of
them but each one of them has some sort
of essence in this straddles both the
supersensible world and the real world
the world that we can see smell touch
and some of these things like the
functions of government exist in both
right so what is he saying here self
consciousness is grasping that it itself
is at the essence of all of these that I
could be the king the bureaucrat the
candle maker
whoever right so he goes out and he says
conversely another way of looking at
this essence an actuality our
consciousness is knowledge of itself
that's a little bit tricky
how is essence a knowledge of itself
through grasping the essence we get to
grasp what it is that we are and this
could happen in a variety of ways
imagine we're dealing with government
bureaucrats right spiritual mass I go in
to get my driver's license renewed and
they treat me as if I'm just a client to
be you know gotten through as quickly as
possible
well I'm learning something about what I
am at least to these people and how they
work and how humanity works in them and
we're also learning about actuality in
that case as well so he goes on and he
says self consciousness is conscious of
its pure personality and therein of all
spiritual reality now is this every
single self-consciousness know if your
self-consciousness is sort of a mirrored
in one of these spiritual masses
and you're just so focused on your your
project right your czaka to use the
earlier terminology running throughout
the reason and the spirit section the
affair that you're focused on then you
won't raise your head above and see this
but if you do and if consciousness has
become raised to the level where
ordinary people can start to have
opinions actual like well-thought-out
opinions about what the government ought
to be doing or where society is going
and not just the sort of knee-jerk you
know it's all crap or this is the best
of all possible worlds sort of stuff but
sophisticated understandings of these
then they are in the role of
self-consciousness there so he says it's
conscious of its own personality variant
of all spiritual or spirituality and all
reality is spiritual all reality this is
Hegel's idealism all right this is part
of what ideal as a means all reality is
spiritual or Geist Iike you could also
think of it as mental all reality is for
consciousness there even if you talk
about the you know thing that's
unconscious well you're talking about it
so it is in fact in some way conscious
you can bring it to consciousness right
you can think about it you can talk
about it so this is very important he
goes on and he says now here's a major
transition the world is for it simply
it's won't own will and this is a
general will now why is Hegel bringing
up will here historically if you think
about not just political philosophy and
not just ethics but sort of the
explorations of how society works what
goes into it connected with a kind of
metaphysics of the human person that we
see being worked out in the modern
period will become
a very important term probably much more
than it is for us in the present where
we have many people who want to say the
notion of will it's you know it's so
old-fashioned we should get rid of it
altogether this is when it was is its
greatest robustness so what is a will we
typically think of it as the Faculty of
choice and we don't realize unless we
know our ancient you know literature
that the very notion of will was
something that had to develop over time
while people were using that very
faculty you'll find for example
Aristotle and Epictetus both using this
term proi racists which gets translated
as choice or Faculty of choice and an
Aristotle it plays them somewhat you
know more mitigated role in Epictetus it
is very very close to what just you know
two centuries later people are gonna
recognize as the will of all on toss
right and it's almost there and that
took a lot of examination of the human
being we are radically self
determinative creatures we're also
determined by all sorts of other things
they conditioned us you know including
our own dumb choices that we made in the
past that then redound upon us and cause
us to do certain things but we do have
freedom that Faculty of freedom that
Faculty of productive choice of doing
things is the will and it's been
conceptualized in many different ways
some conceptualize it you know in such
ways that it essentially disappears
think about Hobbes
for example for whom you know you've
just got all these different impulses
moving around within the mechanism the
human being and the last one that
actually decides things that's the will
that's almost a purely nominal istic
conception of the will more robust
notions of the will include this
capacity to Express
our own personality and to develop our
own personality and to shape ourselves
via the will when we do so we're also
shaping others we're also shaping
society so now we come to the notion of
a general will and Olga - Villa alright
what is the general will it's no longer
just the will of me and that person over
there as individuals as Angeles as Hegel
says in this this passage it is the will
of a larger group then again Hobbes
provides us with a really great way of
looking at this Hobbes tells us that the
only time that we actually have
something like a a general will he
doesn't use exactly that term is when we
have a sovereign when we have a
legitimate sovereign who is you know
part of the social contract and the
enforcer of it otherwise it's just one
person imposing his or her usually his
will upon a strata of other people below
them and that is not a general well
that's a purely individual or personal
will despotic elite ironically
dominating others now this notion of a
general will this is in fact one of the
dreams of both the Enlightenment and of
the romanticism that is emerging as well
and you can see them both clearly
reflected in for example Russo's social
contract right this is a concept that is
playing a major role at the time
particularly in the French Revolution so
Hegel goes on and he says what's more
this will is not the empty thought of
will which consists in silent descent or
ascent by a representative but a real
general will the will of all individuals
as such every rational being every
rational self-consciousness in whatever
group they're in within society ought to
be able to recognize
the general will by recognizing it by
grasping it as what would want to be in
the situation is what is rational they
are in fact taking part in that general
will this is where it gets kind of
interesting and complicated and we
should pause on this for a moment this
is very well worth you know going
through the history of thinking about
unpacking the ideas where they're a
little bit ambiguous Rousseau has this
famous phrase where he says that
sometimes people have to be forced to be
free that is if your own individual
standpoint or your own membership let's
call it within one of these spiritual
masses precludes you from being able to
ascend to and and thereby participate in
the general will in what is good for
society as a whole then perhaps you have
to be coerced force has to be used
against you ideally we try to reason
with you first or we work upon your
sentiments we try to rework them but if
need be we may have to use force to get
you to recognize that what's good for
the whole the totality is in fact good
on a different plane than our mere
individual good for each individual and
for each group within society this is
one of the let's call it problematic
aspects of the Enlightenment and by
problematic here I don't mean it the way
that that some people do we're that's a
stopping point for thought and they say
oh that's problematic so we can't do
that know when something is problematic
that means that it needs to be thought
through more it needs to be talked
through more it needs to be worked
through in in other ways problematic is
not a stopping point it's not an opera
ax a problem is something placed before
us thrown before us in order for us to
work
and in the Hegelian dialectic a
problematic is something that by working
upon we actually make progress
problematic and progress are connected
with each other so now let's let's go on
a little bit further he says will is in
itself the consciousness of personality
isn't that an interesting way to
characterize this Faculty of will when
you think about your own choices your
own individual choices let's say you
dissociate them from each other in an
artificial way that is not really
reflective of your life unless your life
is a total mess and you're just lurching
from a situation a situation with no
memory of what happened in in your past
just trying to solve each problem as
they come along which can be the case
for some people right we're going to
abstract from that and we're going to do
we're going to talk about the will the
way that people doing philosophy of
action do is if there exist
you know spots where everything else in
the past really doesn't exist and we can
look at things in this hermetically
sealed isolation what is your what is
your will doing it chooses things right
it chooses actions it chooses we might
say for some of us emotional reactions
it chooses plans and projects which
cannot be realized at this point in time
but could be later on is that all that
your will does well it considers options
and it may not be that it's the will
itself that does all the consideration
traditionally we said that there's you
know say the intellect or reason that's
also helping out and maybe giving orders
to the will or suggestions to the will
there's different anthropology's that
come up with different ideas about how
this takes place right and it could be
that there's other parts of us as well
that are influencing the will our
appetites desires are unconscious urges
our conditioning
habits culture the story that we've been
telling ourself considerations of the
relationships that we're in but at some
point the will actually chooses or
chooses against by the way you not only
can' will for you can also will against
right
Latin for example there's a little bit
of a digression but I think it can be
very useful to think about Latin has
this you know voluntary right to will to
choose to want it also has no larae to
want against to choose against if if I
am Volans I am choosing for something
right that's a participle describing you
know say a person if I am nolan's I am
saying no no no I definitely I I'm not
saying what I'm choosing but I'm
choosing against that thing you see this
reflected in Descartes when he
enumerates what it is for a being to be
a thinking being in his meditations in
meditation to where he talks about you
know what is it to think it's to use the
intellect its to reason it's to you know
have sense experiences its to imagine it
is to will it is also to will against so
this is an important point as well
willing is a lot more complicated than
we often give credit to let's say we get
away from this abstract consideration of
how we're just willing at this point in
time what do you do with your will or
what do you do with yourself through
your will in your real existence
personality personality tat
just a cognate in the German we express
our personality we develop we reshape
our personality through how we will we
can even
Volition's that bear directly on our
personality I don't want to be the jerk
that I've been all this time without
realizing it so you know that's before
we even get to like the project of so
I'm going to have to do this and this
and this which are also all willed we're
willing something directly about our
personality I want to be a better person
I don't want to take orders from those
jerks over there that is also willing
about our personality I want to be able
to be in harmony with others I want to
be more rational and so far as we're
choosing that will expresses our
personality so he says will is in itself
the consciousness of personality now
we're going a little bit further it's
not just you know pushing I'm gonna be
this I'm gonna be this will is what
allows ourselves to be conscious of
ourselves in an important way
self-consciousness we've talked about
this many many times is not just
consciousness itself but also
consciousness of the other we understand
ourselves in relation to the other but
self-consciousness is also reflective
right and it is so through its will so
now I'll expand the will much larger so
that we're talking about the will of all
the general will as he calls it he says
this will is is you know the real
general will the will of all individuals
is such will is the consciousness of
personality or of each goes on and he
says it is as this genuine actual will
that it ought to be as the self
conscious essence of each and every
personality now we're no longer talking
about the essence solely of social
groups or institutions or organizations
we're talking about each individual
having an essence
and at least in thought if not in
complete reality the self-consciousness
that is grasping the general will is
ideally grasping the will of each of
those individuals out there now this is
going to be an approximate to process is
it not it's not something that I think
we could actually even successfully wrap
our head around think about how
complicated the human beings that you
interact with are just by themselves now
imagine trying to understand their whole
processes of motivation that would be
quite difficult would it not so we're
going to do this you know ideally but he
says the general actual will it will be
the self conscious essence of each and
every personality so that each undivided
from the whole always does everything
this is another key aspect of the
Enlightenment treatment of the general
well the idea and again this goes all
the way back to Hobbes right and it's
not just Hobbes of course so don't don't
associate it exclusively with Hobbes
think about the encyclopedias think
about Rousseau think about all these
other social thinkers on the way to
Hegel but the idea is that by being part
of this general will by being
incorporated into it rather than merely
represented in it each of us will be
doing what it is that the general will
decides so if the general will says this
country has to go to war with this
country we're all at war with them
whether we're on the battlefield or not
if it says we must make progress and
education within our domain
the primary objective then that becomes
a primary objective of all of us even if
we're just sweeping the floor
within the laboratory this is a very
important point there's an
identification of the individual with
the general will that's going on so says
each undivided from the whole always
does everything and what appears is done
by the whole is the direct and conscious
deed of each do not just direct but
conscious each of us is part of this
larger totality this larger whole of the
general will now we've come quite a long
ways how is this absolute freedom this
is what absolute freedom is going to
look like in part for Hegel or you might
say this is how the conception of
absolute freedom that was developing out
of the Enlightenment finally takes shape
and we're going to see whether this
really does hold up or not or whether
there are some problems with it
you